what's the most important part of the
writing process for you I don't know
what the most important part of the
writing process is but I know that the
the thing that I've learned over the
last couple years that's been the most
helpful and the most for me why I
transitioned from more solo performance
and solo writing worked screenwriting
and being part of a writers room is for
me the writing is in it's not an
individual process actually it is for me
I tried to do the thing where you sit at
the desk by yourself and write a book
write the novel write the like bite and
that's just not me I couldn't do it and
so for me I write my first drafts with
people or I get the ideas talking with
people just just what do you think about
this and it's the writing happens
usually before I'm even writing the
writing is in conversation
the writing is trying stuff out trying
ideas questions I asked a lot of
questions and then and then the actual
writing for me is I was I'm still pen
and paper I'm still like I don't start
on final draft I don't start on the
computer because I just the internet
kills me and even not even the area just
the screen there's something about the
pressure of the screen and so I'm still
if it takes longer because I have to
freaking transcribe everything but I get
better I get sooner to the actually what
I want so I always start pen and paper
and it allows me to get free and really
what it does is it removes the editor in
my head while I'm writing if I'm on the
screen I'm like editing while I write if
I'm right just writing freehand I get a
little more that's usually where the
good comes out when you do usually
and you can do something called y:i
right right you stand up and do like
Open Mic different things and and yeah
so I as a writer I got my start as doing
performance poetry and spoken word and
then I moved I did a little bit of
stand-up and then I moved into live
storytelling in this Shana NPR called
snap judgment and so I did that for
awhile and most of that is you know
autobiographical or semi
autobiographical or supposedly
autobiographical but at a certain point
I got to you know I have stories I'm I
can tell you stories about my life and
that's great and I love to do that but
there's other stories as a writer I want
to tell other than my own freaking life
and there's my whole community and my
neighbors and my friends and my family
and I want to do more than just me on a
microphone and so that's you know Yvonne
and I knew each other
just from Oakland and actually you know
we met playing soccer like this is like
we didn't start just working together we
were friends homies playing in a
socialist soccer club in Oakland called
left-wing Football Club and so like we
just I don't even remember how we got
said oh I just wanted to make some
videos it was you know it's early 2010
or something it's like you know Internet
videos blogs vlogs all these things I
was like I want to do something you're
the you're the filmmaker and our crew
let's do something and I think some of
those still exist on YouTube they're
terrible they're freaking off I mean the
cinematography is amazing but I didn't
know what I was doing I didn't know how
to write for film but it's just
experimenting it's trying stuff out and
then little from little you know going
there to making larger videos having
slightly larger budgets and then going
from there to making the web series
you